what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today I'm going to be taking
a close look at chapter 119 up attack on
Titan and looking at the evidence from
the manga to help determine whether or
not
Eren is actually dead as he appears to
be at the end of this manga chapter make
sure to smash that like button for more
attack on Titan videos if you haven't
subscribed and ring that notification
bell so you don't miss any colossal
greatness let me know in the comments if
you appreciate these trap 2 reviews in
particular I'd love to hear from you you
can also get important updates about
attack on Titan and other anime on our
twitter and instagram at anime uproar of
course since we are talking about the
latest chapter in the manga there will
be plenty of spoilers if you're not
caught up now without further ado let's
jump into it in the new chapter we start
out with Zeke still being injured and
Marley trying to prevent the beast Titan
and the founding Titan and Aaron from
coming into contact because if Aaron
comes into contact with the Titan of
royal blood like Zeke then he will be
able to use the fighting Titans powers
Aaron is trying to get to Zeke but he
gets bitten in the leg by the JA titan
era practically karate chops of Jah
Titans head off but then Aaron gets shot
in the head by the anti Titan artillery
that's attached to peak and the car
Titan the whole city is in mayhem the
survey corps is fighting them are laying
soldiers Zeke starts to regain
consciousness he realizes that he fell
to the ground after he was shot and sees
eren's Titan fighting riders armored
Titan while they're fighting
Reiner passes on some memories to Porco
with a touch Porco figures out that his
older brother Marcel talked poorly of
him to the military because he wanted to
save his brother from the cruel fate of
a Titan shifter Zeke is about to turn
the people who ingested his spinal
fluids into Titans before Falco and Colt
graze come rushing to him Colt wants him
to not scream because Falco accidentally
ingested someone his spinal fluid so he
would turn into a mindless tightly colt
wants to protect his low brother above
all else he only wanted to become the
Beast sight successor so that the rest
of his family wouldn't have to be sent
to heaven aka be turned into Titans Cole
tries reasoning would Zeke Colt
tell Zeke that he's not the type of
person who would allow children to
be involved so easily he begs Zeke to
give him time to take Falco out of the
range of his scream Zeke appears to
empathize he says he knows his feelings
towards his little brother well
suggesting that he similarly cares for
Aaron however he chooses to scream
anyways then stuff really starts to go
down there's an absolutely heartbreaking
part with Colt and Falco where Colt
keeps hogging Falco even though he's
about to turn into a Titan a
transformation that would most likely
destroy anyone that close to him Falco
tells Colt to let go but he keeps
holding on saying it's okay and that his
big brother will stay with him always
then multiple titans appear at the same
time across the city including the Falco
Titan Z can now control these Titans and
he sends the Falco time to attack Reiner
gabby is crying her best friend and love
interest just turned into a Titan and
she sees that Colt his older brother is
dead Aaron keeps tried to get away from
Reiner while Falco starts biting into
riders neck at the same time Zeke is
shot again by the crazy powerful anti
Titan artillery then just as a shot is
gonna go off aimed at Aaron's head Armin
and weakest appear behind the car Titan
and stop the attack at this point the
characters believe that Zeek is dead
Reiner believes that as a result their
mission has been accomplished and Aaron
can no longer hope to use the founding
Titan power so he decides that he's
going to let Falco consumed his Titan
power so he can turn into a shifter and
thus back into a human
however Porco shows up he has used up
all of his healing power but he refuses
to drop dead for nothing
he lets Falco eat him and inherited JA
titan power instead then Aaron uses
hardening to trap whiners Titan and
starts running towards Zeek who is
somehow still alive he was only
pretending to be dead Reiner breaks free
but he stopped by the survey Corps and
their thunder spears it really seems
like aaron is going to finally reach the
Zeek
but then Gabi who is clearly an insanely
good shooter for a 12 year old shoots
Aaron's head off Z cries out and it
looks like Aaron really is dead and
that's where the new chapter ends now
the question is is
Aaron our protagonist really dead attack
on Titan has often been compared to Game
of Thrones because of how often people
die people like Marco potato girl and
even seemingly Levi's the most popular
character in the series have been killed
Aaron used to be presented as the hero
of the story but that has changed since
we started getting the Marlin
perspective now Aaron often seems more
like a villain since he's willing to
kill innocent people including children
and go against the wishes of the survey
corps he's mostly been a mystery to us
since the times kid it's hard to read
him and what he's actually been planning
to do I find it hard to believe that he
was ever going to go along with Zeke's
plan to euthanize aldea but Aaron has
also never shared an alternative plan
with anyone so if they could kill off so
many important characters why not Aaron
- who hasn't really even felt like the
protagonists of the series after the
time-skip
we even saw his head go clean off his
body which would definitely suggest he
is dead right well despite all this I
believe Aaron is still alive and the
verdict is still out on Levi - since
only hanji verified that he was dead and
she would want to say that anyways to
keep him safe from the enemy soldiers
aside from the fact that Aaron was the
protagonist from the beginning and he
already got three Titan powers so that
the story would get way more complicated
if you were to die and be much harder to
resolve let's look at the other evidence
in the actual series to see why he's
probably still alive we were told by
Aaron Kruger that if someone who holds
the power of one of the nine Titans dies
without anyone inheriting that power
then the power of that Titan is suddenly
inherited by a baby belonging to the
subjects of yamir distance plays no
factor in this at all and neither do
blood relations all subjects of yamir
connected by paths which make this
transfer possible so in theory if Aaron
died the three time powers he has would
be passed down to three random babies
belonging to the subjects of yamir we're
told that this is what would happen but
we've never actually seen it happen with
anyone in fact most of the time Titan
regeneration has been so impressive that
consuming another Titan user and taking
their Titan power has been the only way
to kill that I remember that one of the
time
I was first surprised by just how crazy
this regeneration ability is was when
the survey Corps took out riders head
with thunder spears his human brain was
completely gone by all logic this blow
should have finished him off
yet his Titan still managed to yell
which was the signal for Bethel to join
the battle not only that he managed to
fully recover with his personality and
the vast majority of his memories intact
bertolt explains that rhino was able to
transfer his consciousness across his
body's nervous system he said that if
you use your nervous system with a
Titans brain you'd even be able to
retain your memories Reiner was attached
to a Titan unlike Eren but Zeek wasn't
when he miraculously survived a
point-blank Thunder spear that was
attached to his body everything from his
chest down was blown away and a little
that remained was severely damaged if we
can believe hanji the Thunder spirit
going off at close range would rip the
internal organs to shreds Levi also
hadn't allowed Zeke a break to fully
recover so he was already wounded and
had used a lot of recovering power
before the explosion went off
nevertheless because of the paths Zeke
was saved he was taken in by a Titan and
his body was rebuilt
she even retained his memories it is
significant that we've witnessed all
these insane levels of regeneration
before this moment where Eren lost his
head people who haven't been paying
attention might think Aaron is dead
but all these crazy instances of
regeneration have led to this point so
that if Eren survives at this point it
wouldn't be out of nowhere the
groundwork has been laid throughout the
manga for Aaron to recover from this
probably by way of the paths compared to
Zeke Aaron's body was completely fine
before the shot
so his regenerative abilities weren't
even as used up as Zeke's must have been
then we add to this the fact that Aaron
was the protagonist from the beginning
and that we have yet to learn for sure
what his angle was and you can see that
Aaron will all but certainly be coming
back it would be one thing if he
sacrifice himself when the issue seems
all but resolved like in code geass but
here nothing is resolved yet and Aaron's
going to need to come back to see it
through and that is my take on whether
Aaron is alive if Reiner and Z can
recover from crazy injuries
I'm sure that our protagonist will be
able to do so as well
he even has three Titan powers which
might even make his regenerative
abilities more impressive but let me
know what you think did you like this
chapter is Erin alive
what is his end goal I can't help but
wonder how Mika some must feel right now
she is conflicted because of the mean
words Erin said but he's also always
been the most important person in her
life and she probably thinks he just
died let me know how you feel about
Falco becoming a Titan shifter and about
Porco sacrifice and have you begun to
sympathize with Gabby or do you hate her
more than ever after this chapter
whatever happens I can honestly say that
I don't think I've ever been as excited
to read the next chapter of attack on
Titan
this one was the king of all
cliffhangers and I cannot wait for all
these questions to be answered and that
is it for today's video if you enjoyed
these attack on Titan chapter reviews
make sure to smash that like button to
let me know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and ring that notification
bell for more attack on Titan videos we
even got a playlist covering a wide
variety of attack on Titan topics that I
strongly recommend you check out you can
also get important updates about attack
on Titan and other anime on our Twitter
and Instagram at anime uproar and if
you're interested in anime merch check
out our store anime up Broadcom where
you can find stuff like the beast titan
beast mode shirt their play of designs
that I'm sure you'll love from all of
the anime we cover so go over there and
check them out at anime out Broadcom a
big thank you goes out to our patrons on
patreon who help make videos like this
one possible I especially want to thank
our pro hero tier patrons the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson ant Kings eldress and are the one
tier patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans baby Ray a17 FF DP Steven and
Radha a Lola autumn Maddy Mac 239 and
makoto-kun and the super special patron
whose greatness cannot begin to be
fathomed regan Harrison the one who has
been acknowledged by Lorde we go senpai
sama himself if you enjoy our work and
it gives you a value you
support more meant by going over to
patreon.com slash anime uproar and
becoming a patron today for as little as
$1 if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these colossal e awesome people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]